backpack backpack backpack what up its
why all the clients its what with your
best effort with all the best math still
can't win without the creative variable
in the gray so basically what you do as
a practitioner is how I think about life
it was if it was that black and white
it'd be over everybody would do it yeah
just not the way it is thank you gay you
got brothers thank you already here are
they ready yeah bring him here thank you
[Music]
yeah you guys will figure it out you
talk to Tyler Z if you're watching this
talk to Tyler I have no idea what the
[ __ ] is going on when it comes to
logistics because you focus on the ship
that matters and logistics doesn't do
not matter
people love logistics to today like
maybe on the back end or maybe I don't
know like or do you want to hold them
off for ten more minutes
oh we're still not ready yet yeah good
talk my man let me see it how are you
miss you too yeah do it I love that
record I love it thank you for your
flowers happy birthday dear
happy birthday hey the second season
Vancouver oh my god you're speaking I
love it I can't wait to rock these Nate
on my team you should get me do rock
let's get neat here
Nate has never beaten me in tennis like
sports is amazing because you keep score
we are Nate this is oh yeah just for a
second just for a second just for a
second Nate as someone who's been
beating me multiple times five two and
then losing what do you think is
happening there in your gut more about
why am i winning
it's less about you Nate it's more about
me too many winners that's interesting
observation and then against in five
three five floors and I get tight its
momentum
thanks Nate and for all the
entrepreneurs that are watching right
now
okay cool maybe you don't have my 800
million dollar business but maybe you
also in parallel rays two phenomenal
kids look what me just said to answer
the question and I know this has been a
very awkward interview like a little
different lifestyle here's the answer
ask it again I'm like I want to add I
want you to ask the question exactly the
same way if you can remember how you
asked for the same energy sure so in the
midst of failure yeah how do you
actually
game positivity and what are some other
strategies yeah that's right yeah I dig
in Nate's answer not mine and you'll be
me a few day can tire that's ass that's
net now you're doing something about it
watch us 70 come on it's the Nate you
like it 70 alright what are we doing
here I've a store eclis been fascinated
by somebody's got to get bumped today
it's got to get replaced somebody else
gets bumped house when is that gonna be
great because that's super hard
well we're spending all our time on is
context context context and the
passenger and your system and who
passing to them why the calendar works
in his little boy and breathable and
we're living it right this second I was
supposed to meet Shelby eight minutes
ago I'm talking about if I'm this late
we're gonna be there two or three rather
too if I'm two hours and change late
right I'm two hours late these two
meetings are now in trouble they're
gonna be there so we're gonna take them
but at the end of this whole spiel when
I leave at 6:30 if something didn't get
picked fit in here that's when we got to
reschedule it right right it's not
something I'm gonna figure out yes do
you know what I mean yeah that's the big
one
YouTube super-focused Long Island City
good day
had a fire meeting I mean just like a
fire meeting that I hope they chopped up
for a podcast clips
I'm sure gear up to find some time for
it in here what else going on Jets
football obviously the least excited for
a season I've ever been it's weird to be
Thursday before the season and not and
not be completely freaking the [ __ ] out
like didn't see myself rooting for the
Buffalo Bills anyways see you later what
up what up what up
such a pleasure how are you my
recommendation like if I was like you
know if we came into this and like we're
gonna be all partners like I quit
vaynermedia and this is my life the
number one move I do is map every single
backpack company in the game from them
if they're number one cuz you actually
like them and it's hot all the way down
to the one that is wack and not hot and
look at it in a room like this and be
like okay reach out to all of them be
like cool yeah what's up guys and like
what can we do and they're gonna say
well we'll give you a ton of [ __ ] we
love you and you're like what about
money no what about equity of course not
if we're not giving you money we're not
getting you equity cool thank you next
you know JanSport we want to bring that
back or I don't know everything's back
JanSport wanna do something yeah what
are you gonna give us free stuff of
course you're gonna pay us sure how much
do you charge twenty thousand votes cool
you want to give us one percent equity
in the company
no cool number three backpack backpack
backpack what up hey you gonna give us
free stuff yep
you gonna pay us yeah how much is it
$20,000 I said did it then you decide
cool thank you next butter hello
backpack backpack backpack backpack
backpack what's up sure
notice how I'm calling everybody
[Laughter]
ready ready ready you're exactly right
let's play it out if I paid you $100 to
wear one backpack for the next three
years would you do it if I paid you
twenty million dollars would you do it
yeah that's the game I'm explaining what
you need to do is get it from no to 100%
[ __ ] yes everything in between and
then figure out the right spot do you
think of course thank you thank you guys
thank love you boy - yeah 2007 the video
blog or video blog podcast was a word as
an effect I saw a video we've been doing
some older stuff and I called the video
show a podcast period it really is a
real pleasure
you'll figure that out yeah but we got
Chuck coming man my name is cute feet EP
powers real pleasure we going this way
yeah
Shayna how do you do n't you house
thanks good good look at this one
impressed man you coming in you join her
are you chilling here come on
life is good yawning keep my stamina
how'd you play well I've heard every
single logic and rationale - why not why
yes why this I'm just gonna say one more
time there is no reason that I should
have twice as many followers you know
then the people I do you know I know the
system that works yeah I got my thing
and I got I know I got a little
something but you do it right and you're
sitting right here with 15.5 you know I
believe in that [ __ ]
so if we can help in any way to inspire
that or put you on to a little
information I'm thrilled to do that like
I'm not as lucky my thing is not as like
it's not as much sizzle and it's not as
it's not as sexy as what you do but I'm
trying to make every single person on
earth know the who the hell I am so I
get it my music like I don't kid it's
not your type of music or you don't like
the music but you're gonna know who I am
if that's your truth then you guys need
to get real serious about distribution
and I don't mean just a song real
serious because the people that know how
to understand the distribution
they're the ones who win there's a
reason that communist countries and
dictators take control the media I'm
excited for it do you think hip-hop
rules the words research awesome real
fast about 30 yes
I'm not listening this is an ancient
this is an HR issue say but they're
gonna take another photo it didn't come
in good pretty mouth really nice to meet
you man no hat today for choreo when
you're storing you dish let's be such a
pleasure that's always nice this report
yeah it's usually much it's great it's
great now what uh how the [ __ ] like that
has no prayer in my world to get anybody
to do anything right so what are you
guys thinking egg whatever I want them
do something right and there's no prayer
right now first of all too much
information
there's no simplicity we're not gonna
get the benefits of Facebook by not
making this Facebook native I'm not good
at like move the pepperoni and the and
you got to spray the glass like I
genuinely mean that like I know that you
guys understand that better this I
[ __ ] understand that's why all my
[ __ ] that has no good sound no good
lighting and no good anything [ __ ]
kills cuz that [ __ ] matters
thanks good good man you were really
built like a [ __ ] truck [ __ ] crazy
alright twenty minutes sorry about that
I'll be done oh my god my pleasure such
a pleasure to see our thanks yeah ready
rock and roll have to go hardcore and do
some remarkable podcasts back-to-back
just had an incredible encounter a
boogie artist I think is just
outrageously talented if you haven't
listened to his music you're not paying
attention Netflix came through they're
feeling they're just [ __ ] cameras
everywhere all the time now Seth [ __ ]
camera on camera on camera first ten
[ __ ] cameras are here all right dude
you crushed that I just did a great
podcast guys phenomenal I can't wait for
you guys to hear at you we actually
talked about a ton of [ __ ] that I don't
talk about often and that's getting
harder than you think so check it yeah
we're you know detox detox super sad
what's a YouTube famous I'm not to head
out I got a meeting with guy oh sorry
and incredible music legend Beastie Boys
Madonna just [ __ ] Internet and not
internet you know entrepreneurial mogul
it's gonna do that Jeff Nicholson had a
media three four-hour meeting with him
I'm gonna chop it up and gotta go sleep
tonight but before I get going
yesterday's just two days ago is blog a
couple days ago blog came up let's
answer a question I'm gonna be getting
in a lot more of this baby [ __ ] I'm
gonna end it with yours brother
wrote please don't bleep out the
swearing we didn't bleep out the
swearing in this episode we believed out
the client I [ __ ] swear from the get
forever and forever and forever and I
will never beat my [ __ ] Fox
everything what why IV cool let's roll
this whole thing let's just roll this
whole there's a perfect way to end guy
sometimes they do dumb [ __ ] without me
knowing about it
see you guys later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Gary you good bro yeah I'm good
Zeon